okay Alexander are you here Alexander
Madhuri because I'm not sure I'm gonna
need the whole second hour so if I run
out of gas
maybe Alexander can get started early
we're also we can have an early break
and then he can have a slightly longer
last session all right okay so Michelle
actually pointed out the break that this
picture isn't completely accurate so
maybe I'll eat up some time trying to
correct it and the reason is that on the
on the predictive steps when you're
starting from inside here you're
actually tangentially heading right for
the origin and so they're going to start
out heading that way and of course
they're gonna like veer away and run
into the outer boundary and so a more
correct picture would look something
like this as the central path is the
outer boundary is the inner one so I
guess you would start here and then you
would start out heading for the origin
but it's talk and you know get stuck at
a point here and then the corrector step
would take you back inside okay and then
you sort of repeat that process
so that's probably yeah the Cory Kubrick
shows actually aligned rights constants
called centering diction
so it's going back towards the middle so
is that it's actually aligned it's not
use these sconces so make sure of
exercise because yeah the summation
stays constant but the actual pairwise
products might be they're still
quadratic something I see but they
somehow cancel out so so you think it's
more like that okay heading back for
there okay good so I'm learning a lot
here so okay thank you alright so here's
another approach that was also very
popular back in the 90s sort of as an
alternative to this explicit pass
falling approach where you trying to
keep all the X OSA products in balance
you can also do that implicitly through
the use of a formula and of course
barrier methods draw their motivation
originally from the log barrier idea as
I'll talk about presently when I just
talked about a primal barrier and so
naturally people were sort of thinking
about how to extend this into this log
barrier idea and a primal dual space and
here's the maybe the most successful way
of doing that you'd if you can define
this function Phi of Rho which is
dependent on X is a products again and
it involves logs and it involves as
parameter Rho and you can define it like
this log of X transpose s minus the sum
of the logs of the individual pairwise
products X is a we're always something
greater than n now by messing around
with us a little bit by adding and
subtracting n Times log mu to the first
terms and the second term actually
subtracting it from both terms you can
write that rewrite that expression like
this so modulo this constant you'll see
there are two terms here and this one
sort of pan eliza's it where the X is a
is much smaller than mu so if one of the
X is OS is much smaller than the average
this is going to be a tiny number close
to 0 which means it's negative log is
going to be a big
so you're going to pay a penalty for
that so and then the first time of
course is because Rho is greater than n
this is something that you're going to
want to drive to minus infinity okay
because you want to drive Mew to zero so
again you see this balance between
trying to stay central by keeping the X
is is close to mu but at the same time
trying to drive the Mew to minus
infinity okay so that's it's got the
same kind of motivation as we've been
talking about already so okay so again
you maintain strict feasibility of all
the Internet's because you want these X
I si pairwise products to be strictly
positive so that they're in the domain
of the log once again you take these
modified search directions based on that
parameterised algebraic system f of
sigma times mu where you choose the
sigma here to be n over rho okay based
on the the barrier parameter Rho and in
at least in the classical methods you do
a line search along this Newton
direction in such a way as to minimize
the the barrier function okay then you
pick the alpha that minimizes the very
function along that direction so the
complete algorithm looks a lot like the
ones that I've already defined on
previous slides in that you just have a
series of iterations you stay strictly
feasible you pick the parameter row up
front you choose the deltas to be the
Newton step for F of Sigma times mu
where Sigma is just n over Rho u you do
you take the longest step that you can
take while staying strictly feasible but
you try to minimize the barrier function
so that will actually kind of guarantee
that you stay strictly feasible then you
just take that step so it's really just
the same sort of search direction the
same sort of line search but just using
a different criterion to choose how far
you go along that direction so what can
you show about this well the the
classical results about this are is if
Rho is greater than n plus the square
root of n you can show that you can get
at least this much reduction in the
barrier function at every iteration a
reduction of at least point one five and
what that means is that you can
therefore drive the very function to
minus infinity at this nice steady right
you can also show that you've got this
relationship that actually falls out of
you know this expression here you can
show that okay you can show that the Mew
is mounted by the exponential they're
very function divided by Rho - hand and
therefore by driving this to minus
infinity you're going to be marching
this steadily it's sort of at a linear
rate towards zero mu mu is going to go
to zoo so you end up with this sort of
complexity the initial value of the
Buried parameter plus Rho minus n times
log epsilon over Delta what is Delta
here I think that Delta is just point to
0.15 Levent yeah I'm looking to event
for confirmation all right very good
okay and notice this is only true for
Roy greater than n plus square root of n
so you can't make this any less than
square root of n okay you're still stuck
with the square root of n here okay
which as far as I know is kind of the
best you can do for these kinds of
methods okay so back to this question of
initialization which which Daniel raised
early on okay so yes another question
yeah
I guess I wouldn't it would look like
that wouldn't it if you meshed all these
together they want to scale all these
individually all these X is size is
typically to even out stuff so a log
already does that it's knowing and
economics is disproportionally fear
utilities that that also works towards
equalizing for the individual terms so
in terms of what it functionally does it
should be similar well no I haven't
thought about this question but I mean
that would correspond to some kind of
rescaling of the whole LP right if you
rescale the rows and columns of of a
that corresponds to applying some sort
of scaling to the elements of X and s
and are you talking about having some
sort of adaptiveness of the way that you
just putting an excited si also outside
oh I see I see having an in front here
yeah I see what you mean I don't know if
that's been studied Levin fight when I
studied or what twenty years ago
okay very good well I talk to you talk
to you
it's corresponds to a nonlinear
departmentalization of the last equation
XS equals UI if you take logs on both
sides component twice and then lose the
Newton direction that's exactly the
interesting all right I'm sorry I'm not
repeating all this for the record that
cuz it yeah that's that's okay thanks a
lot for that alrighty so okay the
question of initialization so it is
non-trivial in general to find an
initial point that's within this
neighborhood and doesn't have an
enormous value of mu naught okay
so there are two things you can do to
fix this up one is you can modify the
algorithm so that doesn't require
initial point in other words it doesn't
require you to satisfy these two
conditions upfront and this leads to
this whole area called infeasible
interior point methods which I'll say a
little bit about so it's sort of a
generalization of what we've been
talking about in a sense and the second
approach is that you can take the
original LP formulation and come up with
a slightly expanded formulation where
the feasible point is obvious where it's
absolutely clear and obvious how to get
a starting point and this is a so-called
homogeneous self-dual idea and then you
can just go and solve those actually you
need a slightly more general tool for
solving them you need an interior point
method from want to turn on in
complementarity which I'll talk about
subsequently as well all right so these
are two approaches I'll say a little bit
about both of them I would say in
implementations that it's the first one
that's implemented most often I do know
about implementations of homogeneous
self-dual but the code that I worked on
20 years ago and the other
I know about tend to user more I tend to
use this formulation more the complexity
gets worse the results for this or have
an order n-squared in them rather than
an N but of course as you know as always
we seem to be we seem to see an inverse
relationship between worst case
complexity and practicality that's
that's been my experience in this space
okay yeah all right
yeah here we go so for infeasible
interior point methods all you need is a
point where the x 0 and s 0 is strictly
positive and we all know how to do that
right so you can just start from the
vector of ones or something so you need
to define these initial residuals and so
when you're doing the Newton equations
you no longer have zeros here on the
right-hand side you have to correct for
the fact that you've got errors here and
but because these two equations are
linear what happens to those terms is
nice and predictable ok there's no
non-linearity in these first two rows
and so these things march steadily
towards zero they're all scaled by 1
minus alpha at every step if you ever
take a full Newton step you immediately
get feasible in those first two
components and you stay feasible
thereafter ok but you give up a bit you
give up the fact that we've got Delta x
times Delta s equals 0 and that came
into that analysis of how long a step
can you take the analysis isn't that I
did in those five easy steps kind of
depended on having this relationship and
that's no longer true and so you have to
generalize some what the analysis does
get somewhat mess here
you still you actually use the duality
gap that still shows up you still make
use of them you
in fact you define this slightly
generalized version of the N minus
infinity your neighborhood and it looks
exactly the same as it did before except
it's got this extra condition in it so
again you have here it is here again you
want X is R to be greater than gamma but
you put in this extra condition that the
residual at the current point that is
the infeasibility in those two linear
equality x' is bounded by this multiple
of mu which is the current value of the
duality gap the feasibility gets
squeezed to zero as mu goes to zero okay
so this is a way of controlling the
feasibility in terms of them you so you
have this slightly more complex
definition of the neighborhood which
means that there are more conditions to
check when you're deciding how long a
step you can take but it's still there
still elementary they're still easy to
check yeah
there is no feasible
yeah good question then this this is
gonna get stuck it's gonna get stuck
it's it's not gonna be possible to drive
these to zero and simultaneously
maintain non-negative non negativity so
the theory depends on having a feasible
solution yeah no you don't with this
method there are actually modifications
where you do yeah I take that back yeah
I probably even put I think you there
are guarantees that you can show that if
if there's a solution whose norm is less
than a certain quantity or something
then it's guaranteed to find it I think
yeah okay
but yeah it's homogeneous self girl has
a much kind of more elegant theory as
far as giving you certificates of n
feasibility which I'll talk about in a
moment but I'm not going to go doing a
lot of details in this because the
spirit of the analysis kind of tracks
what I did so far it just all gets kind
of Messier because of the the need to
deal with the residuals as well but in
the end you're able to show that the
steps that you can take are greater than
some multiple of one over N squared and
that leads to this order N squared log
epsilon type iteration complexity okay
now before I talk about homogeneous
self-dual I need to tell you about the
extension to LC p1 eternally a
complementarity so this is not an
optimization problem it's a math
programming problem but it's not an
optimization problem because there's no
objective there's just a bunch of
conditions you need to satisfy and they
look kind of familiar to you because
I've already showed you KKT so here the
problem is you're looking for two
vectors X and s they're both of length n
you've got a matrix n by n it's positive
semi-definite not necessarily symmetric
and X and s are related in this way s is
just M times X plus Q X and s are both
non-negative and they have to be
complementary so you're just looking for
two vectors X and s that satisfy these
conditions
okay now there's a generalization of
this problem where you can add in extra
unconstrained variables and not required
to be non-negative and and they quit an
equal number of equality constraints so
you get mixed monotone LCPs which have
these extra ingredients but if ever you
derive algorithms for this problem it's
very easy to extend them to the mixed
problem okay so in fact KKT conditions
are kind of a special case of a mixed
monotone LCP these are exactly the
conditions are right on the second or
third slide where I had X and Z and s I
had these equality conditions or there
were just the primal and dual
feasibility I had non negativity and I
had complementarity so this is just the
KKT conditions written in a form that
looks like this
okay yes it is okay if you take Z
transpose this matrix times Z you get 0
every time right it was a homework
assignment I think that's true yeah it's
not symmetric yeah definitely not
symmetric okay okay so so so LP is
really kind of a special case of this
and QP is - if I just take the LP and
put in an extra quadratic term with a
positive semi definite Hessian the Q is
symmetric here in this case then I can
write down the KKT conditions for this
to be this in fact they're exactly the
same CLP except I replaced a zero by a Q
okay and again because the Q is is
symmetric and positive semi-definite
this matrix is still positive
semi-definite okay and so again it's a
special case of a of an LC P okay so LC
p is a it's a great formulation to work
with in fact a bunch of people like
Elena Adler who was here on Monday I
don't know if he's here today he wrote
some of the early papers an interior
point for this problem part following
methods for this problem it subsumes L P
and Q P so several the papers I wrote
also use this framework you don't lose
any generality at all so and also it has
a less notation right just got X and s
and M thank you right instead of X Z s a
B and C so you go from four objects down
- no you go from six objects down to
four okay bonus all right and the
methods are almost the same you know the
path following ideas that log barrier
ideas they're all they're all pretty
much the same the analysis is a little
bit different because you don't have
this Delta X transpose Delta s equals
zero instead it's greater than equal to
zero so in that sense it's the analysis
is a little bit different but basically
the complexity results are the same and
the
convergence analysis looks much the same
that's where the M is not positive
semi-definite and they crop up a lot
like in certain game theory applications
there are certain games that have non
monotone LCP zoom they're much harder to
solve if everything's rational yeah I
guess so I mean ultimately you're gonna
get there's the same concept of a basis
right where we're at any solution you
can divide the X addition to a basic and
non-basic set and once you know that you
can get the exact solution by just
solving kind of a reduced linear system
here yeah so you know I think the same
thing is true yeah okay so now that
we've got the LC peas in the bag we can
I can tell you a little bit in a hand
wavy way at least about this homogeneous
self dual formulation so going back to
LP now we can derive a mixed monotone
LCP from the KKT conditions for LP with
these very nice properties first of all
it's easy to find a strictly feasible
point for this mixed LCP okay
it always has a solution and lastly from
the LCP solution you can back out a
solution a primal dual solution pair to
the original LP or some sort of
certificate of and feasibility so
variant very appealing properties so the
idea is again you just go back to the
original LP give me a point X naught Z
naught s naught with X naught Z no it's
strictly greater than 0 ok so give me
that starting point then I'm going to
define these objects I'm going to define
a B bar which is sort of the initial
infeasibility of this point I'm going to
define a C bar which is the dual and
feasibility of this point that you've
given me
and I'm going to define a T bar which is
sort of a duality gap with a plus 1
added on ok again from this initial
point so given those objects I'm going
to write down this mixed LCP which I
know it like for 3:30 in there 325 in
the afternoon is kind of an ugly thing
to absorb but if you strip out the last
row and column it's just it looks a lot
like the KKT conditions for the original
LP but I've added in some extra
variables that there are a few scalar
variables here Kappa and Terrance and
theta they're all scalars ok and the
capper and the tower complimentary to
each other as before we have the X and s
complimentary just like we did in the
original KKT conditions and we've kind
of got we boarded the original KKT
conditions with this extra row and
column that involve these quantities
that I just told you about now this is
all kind of magic I'd have to go in a
lot of detail to describe exactly why
this works but let me just tell you what
happens is that you can easily write
down a strictly feasible point for that
mixed LCP
you can set these variables the ones you
just add it all to one the tower and the
capper and the theta you just to find X
Z and s to be the original X naught Z
naught s naught that you gave me to
start with to define this problem and
you can show that those that setting of
the variables will satisfy these
conditions okay so it'll be an initial
feasible point for the LCP it will also
satisfy these inequalities it won't
satisfy these complementarity so you're
going to have to run the LCP and to
repoint method to get these
complementarities to hold okay but you
can say you can prove some interesting
results about it first of all you can
show that they do exist
strictly complementary solutions to that
problem and that follows from the fact
that it's closely related to the
original homogeneous self to a linear
program the homogeneous self-dual that
LP is feasible and so on so you'll just
have to take this on faith and then
there are three results that are sort of
classical results in the literature the
first one is that any solution the mixed
LCP has the theta equal to zero the
theta is one of the variables that we
had to add on so the theta equals zero
it means that this last column is going
to be multiplied by zero and what's left
is going to be it's going to satisfy the
original conditions for the primal and
dual feasibility for the original LP
okay so that's the first result the
second result is it if all of the
Strickland complimentary solutions of
the mixed LCP have the capper equals 0
so what shows up in the mixed LCP is
Kappa and tau as a complimentary pair so
if the capper is always the one that's
zero and the Tau is strictly positive
because they're strictly complementary
then you can get a solution of the
original CP by just dividing the Z and
the s and the X or by the tail which is
guaranteed to be strictly positive so if
the capper is zero you can recover a
solution a primal and dual solution for
the original oil CP ok if on the other
hand the the strictly caught if there is
a strictly complementary solution for
which the copper is positive
then you get these infeasibility
certificates okay so if the capper is
positive at least one of C transpose X
and B transpose E is negative that
follows from the relationship involving
Kappa if I multiply out the first row
here you can show that at least one of
those two things will need to be
negative and if the c transpose x star
is negative that means the dual LP is
infeasible if the B transpose E bar is
positive that means the primal LP is
infeasible so so there's very powerful
theory surrounding this this homogeneous
self-dual I'm sorry I can't go into more
detail about it but I've at least given
you the main results yes that is that
particular complimentary problem the KKT
conditions for some other problem or is
it this is just yeah
like I didn't write out what the
homogeneous self-dual LP actually was
but it's a problem where these are kind
of the constraints you can write down an
objective and a constraint set the court
kind of looks like this another way
derive the same conditions yeah you can
write you can write out an LP which
which is almost as big as this and it's
self dual it's yeah it's kind of self
till this homogeneous is a little bit of
a misnomer because there's a non zero
here there's one non zero so it's like
homogeneous to within a single nonzero
but you can write down an LP with an
objective that sort of looks like this
I think it's that x times theta or
something yeah yeah here's my go-to guy
okay so it almost looks these are almost
the constraints of the LP it's sort of
self dual so its dual looks almost the
same do within a single thing and so
when you write their KKT conditions they
sort of collapse down to this which is
almost the original constraint set so
strictly speaking the KKT to the
homogeneous self dual form what kind of
twice as big as this but you can sort of
mash them all together because a lot of
redundancy and you end up with this so
that's why I just I skip straight to
talking about this
okay so so I'm pretty much done with
primal-dual stuff so let me say a few
words about well that's the same that's
that's again you can apply your favorite
path following algorithm to this long
step short step Pro module log barrier
whatever you like and you get those same
complexity results they're going to be
related to n where n in this case is a
total dimension of this thing but that's
like 2n plus M so it's still kind of the
same in
wait so just before we move on so the
infeasible interior point method plus
the S square that it's the best
this one has could have complexity in
brunette yeah it's still the case that
the infeasible interior point method is
better yeah just because they're kind of
when you implement them in practice
there are a few implementation bells and
whistles that really make them work and
it's not so clear including
initialization there's sort of
heuristics for doing initialization but
those I mean there was a car there was a
production code written in the mid
nineties that use this form but to my
knowledge all the codes that are out
there now it used more of an infeasible
framework that's to my knowledge and I'm
not totally up to date on that
Motech uses this okay very good to know
Motech is of high quality code yeah that
was who I had in mind cuz actually the
code that erling right when he was a
high or in the mid nineties who's this
form and I guess he's stuck with it over
the years just question in practice in
terms of like iteration accounts does it
ever go above like yes it does go about
50 but not a lot about 50 this is
something I was talking to Ron Graham
about it the break actually is that in
practice you don't really see much
dependence on n and so it was a bit of a
Holy Grail for a while in the early 90s
to try to find out if there was a method
that didn't depend on n at all just had
a constant bound or a log epsilon down
and as far as I know that's not the case
but yeah but in practice it seems to be
sort of constantly you can't get you
can't get nasty problems where it takes
a hundred iterations or something but
usually for one of these high quality
codes it's usually not usually more than
a few dozen and and I guess I haven't
talked at all about bit complexity but
operation complexity obviously each
iteration cost you order n cubed okay
because you just got to solve that
linear system which is size 2n plus M so
that's sort of an order n queue
the operation so if you bring that into
the if you multiply that by the
iteration complexity hit this Euler n to
the 3.5 log epsilon if you want to go
and talk about bit complexity if you're
assuming all the data is originally
rational and it takes L bits to store
you can show that all of these
operations that you do you can sort of
do them in rational arithmetic or you
can at least approximately them well
enough in rational arithmetic that the
storage doesn't explode and you can show
order n to the 3.5 L in bit complexity
as well metal to understand well is
there no getting further things to get
more sinking on as you get closer this
illusion I mean do you avoid these by
working on this neighborhood you can if
you if you if you're going to a
non-degenerate solution then where the
basis has the right number of elements
and the basis matrix is invertible then
this matrix actually approaches
something nice okay because if you've
got the right number of x i's you know
I'm dealing with an M by n matrix a if
you're heading to a solution where the
right number of X is a positive which is
M the same as number of rows in a that
means n minus M of the S is a positive
if that basis matrix is well-conditioned
this whole thing is actually pretty well
conditioned okay what what hurts you is
that you normally don't solve this
matrix you know normally don't solve
this system in this form you do a bit of
block elimination to get to a more
compressed form and the block eliminated
form is nasty conditioning the first
thing you'd want to do is multiply the
last row by X inverse and subtract it
from the first row because that thereby
eliminating there Delta s is from the
from the whole thing then it that
introduced as an X inverse s here and
that's going to have some elements kind
of 0 some going to infinity and and then
you can go a step further and do another
step of block elimination to get a an M
by M system and that has a nasty
conditioning well it can't have nasty
conditioning right but it turns out the
the the nastiness comes in
sort of a benign way I had a couple of
papers in the late 90s and a few other
people did as well that show that if you
do a careful errand a traditional linear
algebra error analysis on this you can
show that the nastiness doesn't hurt
very much that you still get the errors
crop up in places where they don't
really affect the choice of step lengths
and so on yeah if you got a knife if you
got a pretty nice solution I think I
think you still need that well so LP is
guaranteed to have strictly
complimentary solutions right not
necessarily having the right number of
non-zeros right so what is the well what
is the measure of niceness that would
say something about the condition number
of the system you have to say you would
need to okay I'm gonna have to go back
and look at my papers for this but so so
it's only in the non-degenerate case
everything is cool even when you go to
the highly compressed form in a highly
compressed form the linear system that
you solve is a times s inverse x times a
transpose times Delta Z equals something
okay something on the right hand side so
if you've got exactly the right number
of basic elements that means that the
solution you've got X I positive for I
belonging in the basis and they're
exactly M of these okay and si is equal
to zero and then for the non-basic
sentence the other way around
and not in the basis that's for the
optimal solution right so you want to
keep track of what's happening to this
matrix so this matrix s inverse X it's
the diagonal of X I over si okay so for
the ones belonging to the basis these
these elements are going to be
approaching plus infinity right and for
the ones not in the basis it's going to
be approaching zero okay so if you've
got non degeneracy if the number of
non-zeros in the basis is equal to M
then you've got M of these blowing up
and the other end going to zero so in
the limit you kind of get a weighted you
get a weighted version of a transpose a
but okay what's it going to be
approaching it's going to be the basic
part of a time's the basic part of s
inverse X
basic part of a sentence in physics
towards the basic part of a transpose
alright so if all of these are going is
to infinity at kind of a reasonable rate
at roughly the same rate
this is well-conditioned and square this
matrix is blowing up but is but all the
eigenvalues are blowing up at once so it
can actually maintain a reasonable
condition number and if you maintain the
centrality the central path neighborhood
thing these are all going to 0 roughly
the same rate and so you can sort of
show that that it's not it's not too bad
so if you do have to generously you
can't just say the same thing by
starting with the analytic center of the
optimal phase yeah you can kind of say
the same thing I think I think you can't
say the same thing I'll look at my
papers during the break and verify that
but I think that's true yeah ok very
good
any more questions we've gotten off on
an interesting line right works when you
want to finite arithmetic at least in
theory loads what if you want to do
bounded precision at least in theory for
them many of the places you use it
right okay all right any more discussion
okay I'm letting a lot here
okay so let me just say a few words
about barrier method so the log barrier
idea goes back at least to this paper of
Frisch in 1955 and the idea is whenever
you got a constraint an algebraic
constraint that you want to stay greater
than or equal to zero you just deal with
that by adding a minus log of that term
to the objective weighted by some
parameter so what does that do for you
well if I draw a picture of what that
looks like it's pretty clear that you
need the CI to be strictly positive in
order for this thing to be defined at
all as the log of a negative number
isn't going to work but it's gonna look
like this so this is minus log of C it's
a function of C so the idea is that you
start off with you know suppose you got
minimize f of X subject to CEO a of X
greater than or equal to zero you just
convert that into a parameterised
problem f of X minus tower times log CI
of X okay and when you add in the F to
this as well the f you know it's going
to cause this thing to distort but you
might end up with something like this
when you put both terms in you might end
up with something like that so this is f
plus or F minus tower log CIA okay so as
you decrease tower the region of within
which it zooms off to infinity gets
squished closer and closer to the
boundary so decreasing tower means you
put more and more emphasis on minimizing
the F rather than steering clear of the
boundary of the constraint region and so
you tend to get these contours squishing
up closer and closer the boundaries you
decrease tell okay and so the idea is
that you start out with some modest
value of tower where you've got a nicely
well conditioned function here you take
the approximate minimum of that function
and then you decrease tower do a Newton
method or your favorite optimization
method to find the minimum of
the next version okay the next
parametrize version and you essentially
just track it all the way to until tower
gets small enough and you get close
enough to the solution that's the basic
idea
all right so if we apply that very
simple idea to our LP formulation primal
and dual the member in the primal
formulation we just had X I greater than
or equal to zero well here's where I
whack in the log barrier on the X items
notice I've shifted the waiting term the
MU I've just divided the whole objective
by mu so instead of having C transpose X
minus mu times some of the logs I've got
one of them u times C minus just one
times of some of the logs I keep the
linear constraints around so I still got
a equals B floating around here if I go
and do the same thing to the dual then
I'm doing to this to the dual form
without the estimate without the dual
slacks so I'm using the dual form where
the constraints that a transpose the
less than or equal to C and they're the
things that aren't penalizing with the
log okay and I've got a maximization
here so here I've got a positive log
rather than a negative log okay so
here's the primal dual log barrier pair
and so I can then I can then derive a
primal log barrier by just applying you
know my favorite method to this function
it will have to be not just Newton's
method because I have to keep track of
these constraints so it will be a
Lagrangian Newton type method here I can
just apply Newton's method to each for
each value of MU and then try adjusting
Mew on doing it all over again okay yeah
if you just stick to do all appending
the same
what's that take the dual of this I'll
get this sure yeah I mean these are
closely related again yeah in that in
that kind of way all right
so if I write down optimality conditions
for this problem I I can just write down
KKT conditions for this problem for a
fixed value of MU I get these formulas
that look exactly in fact they are
exactly the central path conditions the
primal dual central path conditions
right so this is strictly what they look
like these are just KKT conditions for
this equality constraint problem and now
if I just define X to be the diagonal of
the x i's as I did before and then
define the SIS to be mu over X I I get
exactly this F of MU parametrized system
of nonlinear equations okay and so the
concept of a central path if you're
dealing with primal or dual log barrier
you basically recover the central path
that you get from the primal dual form I
can do exactly the same analysis by
taking the optimum of the dual of the
dual log barrier form okay so the
following idea let's let's talk about
path flowing applied to the dual because
I think that's what that's the framework
that Aron and Alexander are kind of
going to be interested in so the concept
is just what I said you just write down
the dual log barrier don't you at each
value of MU you take some mutant steps
until you decide that you're close
enough to a solution then you scale them
you by some factor Sigma maybe make it
adaptive if you like less than one and
then take mutant steps towards the new
for the new problem the newly
parameterize problem do the same thing
on the primal except here you have to
take sort of LaGrange Newton steps
because you want to stay feasible with
respect to that constraint so how do you
get complexity results for this kind of
approach well you choose the Sigma
judiciously so that you only need to
take one or a few Newton steps for each
value of MU each time you take you
decrease mu you just take a couple of
Newton's to
and therefore the number of how the
iterations that by how to iteration I
mean each decrease of MU the number of
decreases Amelia need to get a epsilon
decrease in the and the duality gap is 1
minus Sigma inverse log epsilon so
that's how you get your complexity okay
so let's look at this is getting towards
the end here but let's look at what what
a Newton steps look like for when you
apply them to the dual barrier so let's
go back to the dual barrier function
which was here the unconstrained one no
I'm gonna leave the other guys to do
that yeah yeah you can make it
comparable so if you look at the look at
the Sirian you know leaving slides or a
nesterova no Morosky book and so on it
works with a more general form of this
and you can get these or square root of
n as well but the but the end the end
there gets transformed into some
parameter of the barrier function here
I'm dealing specifically with a log
barrier if you're dealing with other
kinds of currents you've got other
barrier functions and I come with other
parameters that sort of govern the
complexity but you might hear more about
that in the other talks okay
okay so let me unpack a bit what does a
Newton step look like when you do Newton
steps on the on the dual barrier
formulation well if I go back to that
dual barrier form and take a gradient
and a Hessian you remember the Newton
step is just the Hessian times step
equals negative gradient so the Hessian
is just going to be a weighted sum of AI
times AI transpose where AIS are the
columns of oh sorry the rows of the
matrix hey and the grading is just going
to be one of them u times B plus the sum
of what is it negative io a times one
over the resistors residuals so anyway I
end up with this that's the negative
sorry that's the gradient that's the
Hessian and that's the step okay so
that's what a Newton step looks like
for the duologue barrier so that looks a
lot like what I was writing down over
here before when I took the primal-dual
equations and compress them all the way
down so in fact you can get a little bit
more precise about what the relationship
is between the dual barrier step and the
primal-dual step so I'm going to go the
other way I'm going to take this these
dual Newton equations and unpack them
into this kind of expanded form where
the Delta Z tilde the dual barrier step
is one component of the solution of a
kind of unpacked system okay so to do
the unpacking I've got to define what is
s well that's easy s is just the dual
residuals and I'm going to define what X
is well I'm going to take X to be mu
over the SI ok where mu is the current
value of the barrier parameter okay so
with those substitutions I can you know
write out exactly what this system is
the a s term turns out a s inverse times
e term turns out to be just a times X
which is equal to B so I can you know
match these two terms together and write
them like that and then now if I unpack
that a little bit this is all just basic
messing around on a sheet of paper with
some linear algebra I can show that the
Delta of Z tilde is part of the solution
of this system ok and this is exactly
the coefficient matrix that cropped up
in the primal-dual setting this is very
much like the right hand side that
cropped up in the primal-dual setting
the first two components are zero just
like they were in the in the primal dual
system here they're zero by design
because of the way that I've defined X
and s but what about this last term well
let me write let me remind you what the
primal dual system was if you happen to
be right on the central path if you
happen to actually be taking a step from
right on the central path then this X
times s times Z is just mu times e ok
and then I can do an apples-to-apples
comparison between the step I get from
the dual barrier and the primal dual
step
and you'll see that the only difference
is in this lifetime and if I compare the
last time the multiple here in the case
of dual Barry it's just Sigma minus one
over Sigma and in the primal-dual case
of Sigma minus one so if the Sigma is
close to one remember Sigma is a little
bit less than one there's close to one
as it is in short step methods or for
primal-dual log barrier methods then
these two approaches are very much the
same dual barrier is going to give you
steps that look a lot like the dual
component of a primal-dual method
however if you're doing a long step
method where the Sigma can be quite a
long way away from one it might be a lot
it might be much closer to zero than one
in fact then these two directions are
quite different but they're the same to
within a scaling okay in fact what
happens is that in the case of Sigma
close to one as in a long step method
the two direction the directions are the
same it's just that the dual barrier is
kind of overshooting it's overshooting
bye-bye amount that's 1 over Sigma
essentially okay so the two directions
are the same but modulo is scaling so
you can actually get I'll write these
this paper with yarra in the late 90s
that showed that you can basically get
the dual barrier method to mimic what's
going on in the primal-dual provided you
solve the primal dual equations pretty
accurately for each value of mu you sort
of home you get pretty close to the
central path you can take advantage of
the fact that the the dual barrier
Direction is kind of in the right
direction as long as you apply the
scaling you'll end up with a very good
starting point for the next value of the
dual parameter which is Sigma times mu
okay so you can sort of exploit the
similarity between the
between the the primal-dual method and
the dual barrier method okay so that's
all I wanted to say I thought I'd leave
off at that point because I think the
other two speakers are going to focus
more more on on the dual barrier setting
and they're also going to have more of
the truth and beauty thing which was
sort of notably absent from from my talk
which was kind of more elementary nitty
gritty tools so any further questions
[Applause]
yeah I don't know because in the LP and
QP and LCP case you only ever used
primal dual methods even though even
though the methods for nonlinear
programming they do have elements of
barium they put the log barrier in but
then they also add these kind of these
these perverse trust regions that ste
you away from the boundary so they've
kind of got elements of log barrier and
primal-dual in a sense if that's the
successful codes for non-linear
programming like nitro and n IP opt sort
of have that flavor there's sort of
primal dual but with with barrier
elements as well but certainly in the
case of L P and Q P primal dual is kind
of as far as I know it's kind of the
only game in town
there's any deeper reason why one always
use the lock function and not just yeah
that comes up in that the log has the
log function has a self concordance
property that I think the other speakers
might talk about where the the second
derivative the log function is - there's
one over x squared the third derivative
is one over X cubed and so the the third
derivative is kind of the second
derivative raised to a 3 over 2 power so
that relationship turns out to give you
some kind of a bound on on the the part
of the Taylor series that you're
ignoring and you know when you're
formulating the Newton step and that
turns out to be critical and sort of
being able to say that the Newton step
is is a good step even if you're a long
way from a solution and that sort of
property that self-importance property
shows up in other barrier functions for
other cards like the semi definite cone
or the second-order kind you get
different functions but they share that
property that's not shared by you know
these other kind of ad-hoc barriers
good question certainly if you're doing
the dual berry formulation you can use
you can use whatever you like to do the
minimization as long as it stays
strictly feasible I did I have seen some
papers like on there was an early paper
by Montero and co-authors for
large-scale STP where they tried doing a
log barrier on the STP where they use
something other than you'd method for
the inner loop I kind of met with a
coordinate dis and or some sort of
gradient I think it maybe was just a
seepage descent method but I don't know
of too much that uses some of the things
that are I mean IP up the NLP codes use
quasi newton approximations to the
Hessians so there if you're doing true
Lagrangian you use the second derivative
you lose the Lagrangian of the Hessian
which you were involved in one june of
the objective and the constraints but
there but in practice they tend to use
finite differences or quasi newton
proximation so that's a different I
guess but it's still a Newton like step
so when I've been talking to I mean some
people will implement like IP solvers
they say that essentially like for
solving the first LP the first initial
relaxation they'll need to use they they
often use interior point methods but the
moment you start adding cuts or
branching or doing it units which the
reasons matter is it's it's hard to hot
start entering point methods so if
you're just solving one problem right
off the bat like a batch problem then in
theory pointers are often very
competitive when you've got a logical
when you're doing a large-scale problem
but if you're modifying that by adding
cuts or adding constraints or adding
variables or whatever it's it's hard to
start to warm start interior point
methods there has been work recently on
making that a little bit better I did
some work in the early 2000s where we
can sort of get a factor of three or
four improvement from a hot start but
not the dramatic improvement that you
get from simplex you know warm starting
simplex from a from a you know a
feasible basis or you can do really well
you can just take a few dual simplex
steps and recover an optimal solution
but you can't get in general you can't
get those kinds of economies with
interior point methods I know that
certainly an interior point is really
good at by the way is where the problem
is very structured so we had a lot of
success in like control problems MPC
type problems which are QPS where the
Hessian is blocked diagonal and the
constraint matrix is also blocked
diagonal so then when you write down
these expanded big linear systems that
you have to solve at every step if you
do an appropriate reordering of the rows
and columns you just end up with a block
diagonal system which you can solve in
order n so rather than order n cubed and
so that's used all through industry and
the MPC control industry uses that all
the time
so it can take advantage in structures
in ways that simplex sometimes cannot
any more questions
if not we're going to come back in an
hour and here the more contemporary view
of how these ideas are being applied man
if you're a nerd laughs another what all
right Stevie the whole hours so there's
finest a long break but thank you Chris
oh no not no longer a short break okay